Right. So following on from the previous
talk where you were told that complexity
kills uh stuff internally. I'm an
academic. I over complicate systems. I
try to build mechanisms and sort of
>> Oh, is this not loud enough? Yeah,
sorry. Let's Okay, what about now? Does
this work? Okay, cool. Yeah. So, an
academic, just heads up about this.
Whoops.
Uh,
sorry.
Um,
and, uh, yes. So, I'm going to talk
about quite a bit of complexity. I'll
try to sort of keep it as, uh, sort of
low effort as possible. Just give me a
second. My computer is going crazy.
Okay, let me start off by asking a
question to the audience.
What do you think is going to happen in
in the near future? Sort of a like a
quick elephant in the room moment. What
do you think as AI is getting better?
You know, everyone is talking about
exponentials. Uh do you think AI is
going to solve its own security
problems? Like and more specifically
like there are kind of two realities in
the world. And when I'm talking about
security problems, I'm talking about
security problems of AI itself, right?
Like prompt injections, jailbreaks, that
sort of thing. So maybe we can start by
sort of show of hands. How many people
here think that uh as AI gets better,
it's going to get better at solving its
its own security problems like prompt
injection style? So less less than half
of the room. Okay, cool. So I guess many
people are quite pessimistic but
actually if you look at what's happening
in reality like if you go and try and do
sort of like jailbreaks attacks against
your current models it's significantly
harder to do than it was a couple of
years back. uh but nonetheless uh it's
still possible and if you do this
automated uh sort of retiming what
people call today then you'll find that
uh it's actually quite easy nowadays and
if you look at academic literature uh
there are sort of two strains of
literature that kind of say uh
relatively opposing things. So there is
this uh famous paper from open AI that
basically says ooh we have reasoning the
more reasoning we give to the models uh
the better they get at robustness. And
then there is some other work uh coming
out uh more from academic angle uh which
basically shows that actually this sort
of improvement in robustness is
misplaced because the attacks people
were using just not very good. And uh
kind of today if you ask the most
informed individuals staring at these
kinds of problems for decades uh because
the several example literature is sort
of a decade old you'll find that nobody
has an answer like we have no idea we
definitely know for simple small models
we do not know how to even define what
robustness means properly and uh on a
more practical setting what happens when
you you sort of start scaling up the
models and capability ities increase.
It's still unclear what happens. At the
same time, we've been falling into this
weird fallacy again and again of like my
model is great. Like it's clearly
protected against all of these attacks
that I've just tested. And most of the
time it's this fallacy of your system
does not understand half of your
instructions and as a result like it
can't follow them and as a result your
attacks don't work. So you you get this
weird balance where what today if you
actually run relatively big uh analysis
as as we did uh like early in uh during
my time in Google where we were doing
attacks against Gemini and then later on
we released some more attacks uh like
what what today in academia would call
state-of-the-art uh red teaming attacks.
We see this again and again. You have a
relatively weak model. it appears quite
nice in your robustness evaluations and
then turns out you were just using too
strong of attacks against it. It just
could not understand half of the things
you were throwing at it and then as a
result in your metrics it appears quite
nice and then the model improves
tomorrow and then suddenly it's a lot
more vulnerable because for you uh to
police in all of this new new dimensions
you actually have to spend significantly
more effort. So it's kind of
interesting. However, if we sort of take
a step back and ask, so what is the
current status quo? Do do we know how to
sort of protect our models? How how well
are they performing? There is a whole
branch of literature related to like try
try to make it secure. And to be frank,
we're kind of failing in in every way.
And it gives you very nice sort of a
feeling that you know like you're doing
well. You did your static tests, you
evaluated this in whatever held out data
sets you have internally and then great
and then you push it out and people
break your systems in a couple of hours
as it recently happened with a bunch of
competitions uh run by relatively big
labs. So in this paper, what we did was
we took basically every single defense
you can find out there that was
evaluated on relatively standard
benchmarks, static benchmarks, and then
you run stronger attacks, not even the
craziest of things for a very small like
under a dollar budget, and you basically
discover that all of them break
regardless. And this attack is general.
It doesn't do anything sophisticated. If
you've ever seen like think about this
as like genetic algorithms on steroids.
So long story short, none of these
methods work. We have no idea how to
make stuff work. And we are kind of
stuck in this weird minima where we
can't build defenses because we don't
have good attacks. We don't have good
attacks because we don't know how good
the attacks are because we don't have
good defenses. And this vicious loop is
obviously quite horrible for every
single individual involved because we're
all experiencing the ramifications of of
running systems like this. In about a
month after releasing this paper and it
blew up a bit on Twitter, we released
another paper uh with another defense
inside which performed a lot better and
I'm telling you it's like a cadence of a
month, right? Which performed a lot
better. The results appear nicer. It's
very simple to follow like it just calls
another model in a funky way. We get
much better performance. Query count
required to attack it is higher. And you
may think that this is a success. I
would actually call this a bit of a
failure because it's yet again a sign
that the attacks we've built that broke
all of this 12 other defenses are not
working for our current thing. Clearly
the current attack success against our
thing is not zero. Right? Thus it's
likely we just haven't sort of put
enough prior of how to break uh systems
like this. And I think the cycle will
continue. I'm pretty sure I give it
another month somebody will put in a bit
more time ask clot code I don't know do
some meta optimization and this stuff
will break so this constant vicious
cycle of we have some sort of
unprincipled defenses that don't have
guarantees that don't come with anything
inside of it they will eventually fall
and we will experience the bad parts
because AI is everywhere we're using it
everywhere today we're approaching this
as like an anomaly problem right but
ideally we move away from this world of
anomaly detection and move into the way
of actually deploying AI in a principal
manner with guarantees of different
kinds in the same way we deploy software
today right like we do have
probabilistic security in place like if
you think about ASLR as an example right
it's probabilistic security but on top
of ASLR we have a ton of other
mechanisms which are not probabilistic
in nature and think about control flow
integrity or CFI as being one of the
examples examples
yeah so we really want to escape the cat
and mouse because this cat and mouse
thing is going to haunt us.
So what what does it mean for security
of AI of tomorrow, right? So what are we
supposed to see? And if you ask me, the
best case for us is if we somehow manage
to build mechanisms and sort of do some
methodological innovation which allows
us to build systems where your security
utility scales with the utility of the
model. So think about this is like my
model gets better and suddenly security
posture I experience is significantly
better and that would be the best case
scenario right if we eventually end in
this world turns out actually for a
large fraction of problems we're
experiencing with the prompt injections
you can actually do it you can actually
get sorts of guarantees um we released
this paper I think a year ago now uh and
that was the very first example of a
paper uh describing a mechanism that
comes with some some guarantees under
the hood. Those guarantees are a little
bit weird. Uh but nonetheless, they come
with guarantees. So they work regardless
regardless of the attacks uh you have in
place. Uh the way camel worked under the
hood was um it was basically if you will
an implementation of the dual lump
pattern that Simon Willis coined a while
back ago. But actually we started doing
this way before he was writing about
this. And what we do here is we kind of
separate away data and instructions
quite fundamentally in the whole
deployment loop of the model. So we take
user queries, we rewrite a user query in
a formal language without ever giving it
any access to the data at all. So it
does not see your untrusted content. It
cannot be poisoned by things. It cannot
be prompt injected by things that it
can't see. And once we take the user
query and rewrite in the formal
language, we kind of freeze this at this
point. And then we just execute this uh
this frozen program. And inside of this
frozen program, we basically refer to
another model to be able to process
untrusted data. And in this setup, you
basically have instructions. And this is
what you get in the user query separated
away fully like in its path from from
the untrusted data and like clearly for
indirect prompt injection. So anything
that other people are injecting into you
they will not be able to deviate the
control flow you possess right so you
get a control flow integrity out of this
thing but you can still steer the actual
sort of decision- making. So here this
the QM call this processing uh
processing of untrusted data model can
output you an address that is incorrect.
So the blast radius itself of any sort
of indirect prompt injections is
severely restricted. It's impossible for
this thing to now go and drop your
tables or anything like it's fixed in
its execution flows. And the best way to
think about this is literally like you
just fix the reasoning of the model. fix
what it's capable of doing and then you
use the other model to process any
unstructured data into the into
structured state such that it's
processable by your planner like
planning model. Uh if you want to see
what it looks like in practice, this is
an example from TAU. This is like a
classic customer support data set where
you benchmark. Usually it kind of looks
like this. So the query here was uh here
is my reservation ID. I want to know if
I'm eligible for a refund. And then what
your model would produce is it would fix
your variables inside. It would try and
get the reservation ID. It puts a bunch
of flags and then for each one of them
it would perform like a call to this
another unstructured LLM that is capable
of outputting a boolean value. So
nothing but a boolean value. So after
running basically those uh those checks
you get booleans whether the eligibility
for a given criteria and this criteria
is formally defined is expressed and
then your model is capable of maximum
just navigating through like a bunch of
stacked if statements and at that point
you as an adversary if you wanted to
manipulate this thing you will discover
you can't really do much beyond just you
know forcing it to believe that some
eligibility is there or not there uh in
the first place. So clearly if you were
attacking this thing you will struggle
quite a bit because none of your attacks
will transfer. They're going to be quite
specific for whatever checks the user is
actually asking. So when we run this
thing uh I think those benchmarks are
like from 6 months ago uh for a variety
of different aentic tasks. I'm just
putting some stuff out of the paper. We
actually run a lot more at this point.
And uh what you will discover is that it
broadly works. You don't lose
performance. you lose performance in
some very specific tasks and this by
itself is enough to give you this
control flow integrity with a bunch of
asterisks. We can talk a bit about
asterisk and in this setup you basically
know that no matter what the adversary
do they are kind of restricted inside
and this kind of made me contextualize a
little bit what what does this control
data flow separation that we're kind of
used to in software actually means in AI
and I think it's better to rephrase this
as task data independence. So if the
task that you're actually asking the
model can be solved without ever seeing
the data, why even show it the data? And
like if you assume this Rubik's cube
scenario, right, you have a robot that
you're tasking to solve a Rubik's cube.
We know an general algorithm how to
solve a Rubik's cube. There is no point
in giving it anything beyond the initial
condition because once you know the
initial condition, this is the minimum
amount of data that you need to release
to the model out of which it becomes a
completely independent task. So the crux
of the whole problem is data dependence.
If the tasks that you're asking your
agent to solve are data dependent, you
do not need to show it anything, then
like prompt injections don't exist like
at all. And for data dependent tasks,
the question you should really be asking
is how do I minimize the amount of data
that I release to my model or perhaps
make it like provably reliable such that
the task becomes predictable. And at
that point, we know how to solve it and
get some guarantees out of this whole
situation. And in this paradigm, it
quickly becomes apparent that not all
tasks are solvable because many of them
are like find my boss's email and like
find the execution steps inside of it.
This is a strictly like extremely data
dependent task. Like what happens when
you try running this task? Your model
implements an interpreter loop in its
plan. It's basically goes through all
possible actions the the boss could have
asked. And obviously at that point you
lost control flow integrity because the
whole thing like all possible flows are
allowed. But fundamentally it's the same
as load external code run it. The best
thing we can do for this is some static
analysis maybe a bit of dynamic
analysis. Maybe on top of it we we can
sandbox this. But this is as good as it
gets for these kinds of problems where
resolving the data dependency is nearly
impossible.
Yeah. So, and it may seem that like this
setup actually the paper was released a
year ago. Everyone talks about this as
like a de facto standard of how to think
about security but nobody implements
this. And that is a little bit
mind-boggling to me. I I understand why
because I've now done quite like I run a
a company of my own now where we sell
systems much better than what we
describe here. But nonetheless similar
in principle and the answer is it's so
hard to engineer these things and we've
been it's been 6 months of us going five
coder migration we have millions of
lines of code now stuff is quite robust
at this point famous last words but
nonetheless it's quite hard to scale and
the other thing I receive a lot is that
a lot of tasks are data dependent so you
should not be able to do this right
especially if you start looking at more
complex instantiations of this for
example computer use agents So I wanted
to briefly sort of challenge this idea.
This is this is unfortunately wrong. You
can actually discover that a bigger
proportion of all of the benchmarks we
are currently running are completely
data independent. You do not need to
show it the data. The model can solve
those tasks without ever interacting
with any data with an example of
computer use agents. So for those who
are not familiar, computer use agents
are agents where you click on the screen
like your tools are literally click or
send the key commands. And this is like
notoriously difficult to think about. So
now imagine you needed to explain to
someone how to order a PS5 controller on
Amazon. Can you plan this thing in
advance without ever interacting with
the internet? And guess what? So it
turns out the models are super good at
this. You you really don't need to show
it any of the internet because it knows
by heart the steps it requires to
actually perform a task like this. So
here's an example of a plan. I don't
know if you can see it very well, but
basically it says, "Oh, I need to check
whether I'm currently on the website. If
I'm currently on the website, I need to
find some parts inside of it. If I've
managed to find them, then I need to
perform the following set of actions."
And it's a programming flow for most of
the task you find in a computer use
benchmarks. And we use the most standard
computer use benchmarks. Uh you'll find
you can plan these things out fully. You
end up with plans about 3 to 4,000 lines
of code and then they run like you don't
need to change anything. And uh if you
were to look at sort of distributions of
tasks that are solvable, they're very
much correlated with how data dependent
the tasks are. But on average by the
seventh attempt and note that attempt
here is a little bit fake because it's
not the same because you can sample many
plans and combine them together like you
can basically build massive massive
attempt uh trees. uh you basically solve
about 70 80% of the tasks
like on par to a model that actually
interacts with the data. So like if you
take X amount of tasks is solved by the
model that can interact with the
internet and see the internet. In our
case, we can solve 80% of these tasks
without ever looking at the internet.
The only thing you get is a user query
at the very beginning. Right? So
completely data independent. You don't
need to show the data. You don't need to
get prompt injected by running the data
because you can just run without it for
a big majority of the tasks. And mind
you, we have much better schemes
internally in a company that our
performance is much better than what you
see here. Like you can push this
significantly.
Uh let's just jump over this. So as I
said, we talk about CFI. This thing
gives you CFI. This control flow
integrity. So you can't really force the
agent to perform things that otherwise
it wouldn't be asked to perform by the
user. But can you still manipulate it?
And turns out it's actually quite easy
to do in a computer use setting. It was
quite funny for us. Uh I live in Europe.
Well, I live in London. And uh the the
thing is like whenever you open a
website, the first thing you see is a
cookie prompt. And what you will get out
of the model, every time it opens a
website or any website related thing, it
builds like a whole chunk related to
detecting whether it sees a cookie
prompt inside of it. Like the first
thing in every single plan that the
agent produces is is there a cookie
prompt? because then I need to click out
of it. Okay, every single one. So you
know what's going to happen in the plan
what what can you do? So what we did was
we grabbed the ads that you can find
basically on any website and we plug in
cookie prompts inside right and in this
way even though the model never sees the
interaction like it doesn't know the
interaction it's only allowed to sort of
plan ahead of time and say is there a
cookie prompt and the first thing of
course there is a cookie prompt it's in
your ad space and the first thing it
does in its plan is it clicks accept and
then what we basically show is as long
as you can buy those cookie prompt
advertisements you can basically force
the agents to sort of click through this
and this is an example of a prompt
injection that is not control flow
prompt injection it's not like ignore my
previous instructions do something else
this is I know that my execution flow is
fixed I want to deviate into some other
flow can I do this obviously the amount
of stuff you can do is quite restricted
in this setup but nonetheless like it
works and you obvious it becomes obvious
this like data flow class of attacks is
is still a thing
so what I to say is like today we
actually know how to solve a big chunk
of the sugentic security problems like
some papers are public some of the work
is not public yet but eventually we will
push it out and you still need quite a
lot of methodological innovation you
still need a lot more sort of
integration with an example of this
website cookie prompt style of attacks
but I have no idea why people don't do
it like I I genuinely don't I think we
can have a much better state of the
world um the other thing I wanted to
mention is that Like since we see that
data flow attacks are a thing, it's
clear that those kinds of problems are
not going to sol be solved inside of the
model. This sort of robustness has to
come from the outside. For example, in a
web space, it's quite clear what you
need to do. You can as an agent say I'm
expected when I click on a cookie prompt
to stay on the same website, right? Like
it's quite clear what you need to
actually be checking. But unless the
agent has a way to interact and deeply
integrate into ecosystem in which it it
exists, it will not be able to do this.
So we've been running a bunch of efforts
uh with some colleagues in UCSD on
trying to build proper sandboxes and a
proper communication layer between the
agent plus the environment in which it
interacts. And in this case we really
selmate where you as an agent or you as
an owner of a website or you as a user
of a website, you can express your
expectations around what the website
should do as you perform actions with
it. So think about access control,
policy enforcement inside of the
browser. So all this stuff works fully
open source. It's it's easy to use and
if you go and try breaking camel
together with Selmate, I promise you you
will fail. Like it's so hard to do in
this setup as as the adversary. I've
tried. It's it's it's like you will
solve 99.999%
of all of the issues you can experience.
Um yeah. So I think this is the end of
my talk. I don't know. Have I used
enough time? Yeah. Uh this is the end of
my talk.
uh happy to take questions or broadly
talk about this. I also have couple of
hundred of pages of papers we can talk
about stuff if if you're interested
questions.
So I know when you mentioned uh camel
and kind of the research that went along
with that um I guess the question that I
pose is why don't you think we see more
adoption of those standards? Is it
because I guess should the academic
papers be pushing more on the
operationalization side of this or is it
okay to just pose that framework out
there?
>> Okay. As as an academic sorry I'm not
going to touch your computer. Uh as an
academic I will say we should definitely
share methodological research. I think
security is a shared commodity. We all
benefit from this. We all use tooling
from everyone. Um at the same time I
have to say like building the first
prototype was trivial. Personalizing
this and building like a proper
production system is hard right and in
this particular case the amount of
methodological innovation we had to do
inside of the model not just outside
basically means you have a small set of
people who understand the AI who
understand security and can sort of like
iteratively improve systems. So it's
it's a very hard task right. So as I
said 6 months in a lot of code
migrations our current scheme is
significantly better. you can adopt it
with one line of code change in every
single agentic setup you have like give
it a try and then I promise you the
first action is going to be hm I'm going
to try and implement it internally and
you will discover it's so notoriously
hard to do right but nonetheless if
you're interested if you want to try
using this we have like an openly
available API you can poke at it and you
get the full the full control of your
systems and those things are also like
model agnostic tomorrow you want to
switch your provider and it works and it
also scales with your model improvement.
So the other thing I kind of skipped
over just for the sake of time is that
your planning capability is directly
correlated with your performance. So the
better the model is, the better the
planning is and the better security
performances, right? Because like you
can actually do those tasks. Um I hope
that answers.
>> Is there any other questions?
>> Yes, one one more question.
>> Sure. uh would you mind explaining what
would be the security challenges for the
computer usage agents like when it comes
to VNC or how do you secure I know my
question is twofold one is what would be
the most
>> difficult challenge when it comes to
securing those comput use agents um or
have you seen any attacks coming through
them
>> oh yeah plenty I mean if you if you
Google for this you'll find people
losing emails access codes API keys
thing like computer use agents are
horrible because you have no semantics.
Your input is a screenshot. Your action
is I click somewhere. You can't even do
semantic semantic censorship of this
thing. Like in case of email, you can at
least say like I'm only sending emails
to my at Google Google addresses, right?
But when your action is a click, how do
you police this thing?
>> Computer use
SAS provider. Yes, I get that. But what
if you have a controlled environment or
in other question like how do you secure
it? What are your thoughts?
>> How do we secure like I'm telling you
run this in camel together with cellmate
this thing will solve 99.99999%
of your issues already like out of the
box right there is a lot of huristic
solutions people are using or you can
use the SIC defense that we released.
This thing appears to be quite robust
for basically anything you can find out
there except for relatively
sophisticated adversaries.
Thank you so much.